因为我现在是人生可能是个死局，
我五姐我今年36岁，
然后是已婚，
我跟婆家呢都是在省会城市，
婆家呢我现在有两个孩子是双胞胎，
我二一年生的孩子，
但是双胞胎呢，
因为早产，
就是二宝，
医生诊断的话属于说是老瘫嘛，
但是他是早瘫中比较轻微的，
可能影响走路，
就最终的矛盾的话，
可能爆发点在这里吧，
我婆家呢，
就是孩子的爸爸是独生子，
公公婆婆都是有退休金的，
但退休金不是属于那种很高的，
加上就他们有闲置的房子，
房租的话，
一年的收入大概在12块钱左右吧，
孩子的爸爸也没有在外面上班，
他是跟着我公公一起做的是小生意的，
但是呢，
因为这个状态他是没有收入的，
所有的经济大权全部掌握在公公婆婆手里。
现在非常痛苦的就是。
婚前是一个经济独立的一个男孩子，
我收入的话一年大概在20家，
我自己婚前也买了两套房子，
也都是在省会城市，
也有车，
就是我的性格的话，
算是比较独立强势吧，
就现在注入到这种经济受人牵制的这种状态，
我非常的痛苦。
第4呢，
就是还有我觉得我现在是人生可能是个死局，
我无解，
就除了这个经济这方面的，
另外的就是我们家孩子的这个问题，
因为孩子需要常年的康复嘛，
当时考虑到孩子要康复，
所以我就把我的工作给辞了，
那全程大家带孩子，
我是没有收入的，
那孩子爸爸也没有收入，
所有的花销都是让经过公公婆婆的，
那孩子的爸爸关系也不是特别好，
因为她是个妈妈，
我婆婆就全面掌控我们所有人，
你老公为啥不出去干活挣钱呀？
因为我公公家不是有一个小生意嘛，
他就等于在他爸爸的手吧，
我跟着他爸爸一起做一些小生意，
这些小生意的进账都是在我婆婆公公婆婆手里的，
就是他没有自己独立的这个收入，
然后呢，
我跟孩子的爸爸呢，
就是经常吵架，
第一个是因为经济，
第二个是我们的性格不合，
我觉得我们的三观严重不合吧，
他是一个非常，
我觉得是没有素质，
没有底线的人，
他会因为我们家老二生病的这个事，
这老太的这个事情，
他会谩骂我，
他觉得是我的责任，
我现在呢，
其实我想过很多次，
我要最终的原因还是因为败在孩子的身上吧，
孩子6个多月就生了，
在朋龙乡住了一两个月才结婚家，
哎，
太可怜了，
不多月就生了孩子，
老遭罪了，
不知道这样的问题我应该怎么解决，
或者是怎么样来调解我内心的这种矛盾，
你爸妈是干啥的？
以前我年纪小的时候，
他们就。
在农村呀，
后来到了我们的这个城市里面，
我们家也有房子，
有门面，
就是普通的上班的，
也没有退休工资，
因为你家老家是农村的嘛，
我有个弟弟，
弟弟家有两个孩子需要带，
如果说我要是带孩子的话，
是没有人帮我带的，
再加上我们家的二宝说要常年的康复，
也有花销，
家里兄弟姊妹是几个，
我一个弟弟和我弟弟条件怎么样呢？
其实姐的经济条件还好，
因为我爸爸妈妈在市里面也买了门面房，
买了住宅，
我弟弟自己也买了一套住宅，
是全款的，
那娘家还可以，
你跟娘家感情怎么样呢？
跟爸妈的感情和弟弟的感情，
我我们感情都挺好的，
但是目前父母又没有退休工资，
他们也不能闲置在家，
没有收入，
嗯，
我妈就在帮我弟弟家带孩子。
我如果要带一个孩子出来的话，
我。
家里人其实是帮不了我太多的，
现在需要龙飞律师帮你解答的问题是什么呢？
我现在呀，
其实第一个呢，
就是我孩子不要，
第二个呢，
就是我现在选的这条路，
就是我还是把孩子的爸爸哄好，
然后我咬着牙继续过，
为了孩子，
我上个礼拜去医院诊断了，
现在是重重抑郁啊，
所以我在给你的留言里面，
我说我现在人生是死局无解，
但是我。
自己又是一个个自尊心比较强的人，
所以我现在在妥协，
伪装，
和内心的这种尊严，
这种交急，
这种纠缠，
我无法平衡，
我很痛苦，
婆婆对怎怎么样，
婆婆对孩子好的话，
你先出去找工作。
王菲女是现在最主要的，
就是因为我们家二宝现在长期需要康复，
因为家里是两个孩子，
婆婆只能看一个，
另外一个要康复的孩子是我从早带到晚的，
就是他们家人觉得我现在性格特别的不好，
性格不好我觉得是有基础的。
第一就是孩子的爸爸是个超级妈宝男，
我们家孩子无论是从吃喝拉撒，
还是洗澡、
看病、
打疫苗，
这些所有的事情全部都是我一手包揽，
关于孩子的事情他从来不伸手，
我们家双胞胎的孩子现在3岁了，
他爸爸没有给他们换过几次尿不湿，
没有洗过一次澡，
孩子夜里生病了从来不管他，
跟我们是分房睡的，
因为他觉得孩子很吵。
就如果啊，
婆婆能帮你带孩子，
然后假设你出去找工作，
因为你一年是能挣20万的人哦，
然后你在婆婆这边的话，
再给她请个帮手呢，
请个小时工，
就是白天在这儿帮你，
呃看着孩子，
呃，
盯着孩子的康复，
你晚上回来了，
自己还能带带孩子，
这种有没有可能呢？
之前我们家请过阿姨，
后来因为宝宝康复的事情，
可能也觉得潜能都没有我自己作为母亲用心，
我们家宝宝现在康复的很好很快，
在整个康复机构里面算是能够排得上前三的，
就是恢复速度最快的小孩，
我觉得跟我自己非常用心，
亲自带小孩肯定要有一部分原因嘛，
最终我还是考虑到孩子，
我不想拿孩子的健康去赌气，
所以才现在被他们拿捏。
最近发生了一件事情，
就是9月份我跟他爸爸吵架，
因为孩子的事情嘛，
他爸爸啊，
拿这个做菜用的切菜用的东西指着我，
然后我跟他道歉，
然后我跟他道歉了，
当时晚上我没有发作，
第二天早上我带着一个孩子就出门了，
出门待了两天，
她象征性的就去看了一下，
就一直打电话，
我婆婆也打个电话给我，
其实我婆婆是知道这个事情的，
但是她伪装她。
知道这些事情都是我后来在家里放了设备听到的，
她跟别人聊天，
我听到的我婆婆是那种心眼子特别多的人，
她表面上跟我自己是那种特别通情达理的婆婆，
实际上我在家里放了设备以后，
我听到了他们聊天，
他是赞成他儿子，
他跟他的朋友聊天，
在我们家打电话聊天，
说他儿子他100个赞称妹妹，
呃，
就是你的这个情况确实是比较困顿啊，
就如果你现在已经诊断出来有严重的这个精神方面抑郁方面的这个问题了，
你先顾着自己吧，
只有你把你自己顾好了，
才有可能将来能顾好孩子，
如果康复这个事情只是说你做的更好，
但是别人也不会做的很差，
也能按部就班的去做，
那毕竟也是他的亲孙女儿，
也是他的亲血脉，
嗯，
就是你先顾好你自己先出去找个工作，
然后指导着你婆婆也好，
找个人也好，
指导着他们一边康复或者干嘛的，
或者说如果这个康复的时间，
比如说有有一年的时间，
这孩子就基本上能够恢复正常了，
咱就再忍一年。
明年孩子应该就下半年，
差不多应该就快好了，
可以上幼儿园了，
我现在就不断的安慰我自己说。
我可以忍，
我还可以忍，
我可以忍啊，
年年下来，
你别把这一年当成是忍，
你把这一年当成是什么呢？
就跟修仙打怪一样，
我告诉你，
任何家里的婆婆都一样的，
婆婆是99.9%，
就是向着自己的儿子的，
这个你不用难过她连我跟她儿子在房间怎么睡觉这件事情她都要管，
她所恿她儿子跟我分房睡，
而你心里面已经打好了主意，
总有一天要离开这个家的，
所以你在心里也没有必要把她当成婆婆看。
但是现在因为两个孩子还需要婆婆的帮助，
你把她当成一个工具人，
笼络还是要笼络，
该说好话还是要说好话，
这个东西不是是情感上的下跪，
而是你把自己当成一个主体，
把所有周围的都当成你的工具人。
你先琢磨明白你自己想要什么，
你想要儿女健康，
那现在我做的所有东西不是为了谁傻贵，
是因为我想让我我的女儿能够有一个健康的人生。
这么想问题啊，
我现在就选了另外一条路，
我把孩子放住，
我放下自尊哄他了，
就是我顺着他说，
我试图站在他的角度来理解他，
我现在没有自我，
也没有自尊，
我放下我自己。
为了我能陪着孩子，
为了孩子能够及时的这种康复，
对咱们再就是修仙，
像那个修炼一样啊，
咱们再修炼一年，
就是孩子可能就有一个圆满的健康的正常的人生了，
咱们就在训练一年，
现在你就记住你的身份，
我是我的人生故事里面的那个主角，
现在我的老公其实不是我的老公，
我的婆婆其实不是我的婆婆，
他们是我人生故事里面的NPC，
他们是我人生故事里面的一个，
就像机器人的设置一样，
我现在需要做的是我怎么能够拧动这个机器，
拧动这个情绪的开关，
我能让这俩NPC别拖我的后腿，
别伤害我的孩子，
别影响我打怪通关，
别影响我修仙吗？
当你决定了，
当你早晚有一天要离开这个家庭的时候，
好，
你现在面对的不再是你的老公，
不再是你的婆婆，
他们两个只是你人生当中的一个配角，
我现在需要做的是我怎么做能让这两个配角发生一点点价值。
我告诉你，
你可以再连一些心理咨询师，
再连一些情感主播，
再连一些能听听你的。
故事帮你出出主意的，
别人啊，
就这样啊，
那这些话我也不敢对我爸爸妈妈说，
我到现在他们都不知道我有这个意义，
就我也没敢说，
我怕他们担心，
对你在抖音里面，
你在搜看哪些那里博主啊，
讲的比较好，
你又比较喜欢他的，
你还可以连别的。
加油啊，
记住，
你就把他们当成NPC，
把它们当成你的故事里面的配角，
你现在需要做的是，
我怎么让这两个配角还能发生一点价值，
还能产生一点作用啊。
我只是觉得人生的反转太大了。
以前。
我也是一个非常独立的女性，
自己买了房，
买的时候我也很傲娇，
不知道现在为什么又会走成这样，
有的时候是我们也不知道是因为什么原因，
也不知道是因为什么，
可能就机缘吧，
但有的时候就是当一个本来被命运宣判成脑瘫的孩子，
能够遇到你这样一个善良的有责任有担当的妈妈，
这个孩子能够有一个圆满的人生，
能够有一个正常的人生，
就这件事情本身就是生命给我们最大的一个奖杯。
如果你的孩子遇到一个没有责任心，
没有担当的妈妈，
可能这个孩子一辈子就是一个残疾儿童，
但是他遇到了你，
你有责任心，
你爱他，
你有担当，
你愿意为他忍耐，
可能这个孩子就能够得了一个正常的人生。
对于我们当妈妈的人来说，
就是一个生命的奖杯，
就这样啊，
谢谢您魏律师。